la mayor central de Europa volvió a ser
atacada mientras se intensifica los
bombardeos en la región de saprilla
tanto kiev como Moscú se culparon por
las explosiones el
régimen de kiev naces en sus
provocaciones con el objetivo de crear
una amenaza de desastre Industrial en la
central nuclear de zapolilla el 19 de
noviembre la artillería ucraniana lanzó
11 proyectiles contra la estación en la
mañana del 20 de noviembre la estación
fue bombardeada dos veces por militares
ucranianos entre las 9:15 y las 9:45 de
la mañana se lanzaron 12 proyectiles el
operador Estatal de energía nuclear de
Ucrania dijo que las explosiones eran
bombardeos rusos que habían dañado las
partes de la planta necesarias para
generar electricidad y es parte de una
estrategia más amplia destinada a
destruir la infraestructura energética
de Ucrania antes de la llegada del
Invierno solo el sábado Ucrania informó
de 400 ataques en todo el país y
millones de civiles se enfrentan a
temperaturas bajo cero sin calefacción
el organismo Nacional de energía atómica
ha estado en repetidas ocasiones a no
utilizar el emplazamiento como Peón de
guerra y ha pedido ambas partes que
establezcan una zona de seguridad
alrededor de la planta
se produjeron explosiones en el sitio de
esta importante planta de energía
nuclear lo cual es completamente
inaceptable quien quiera que esté detrás
de esto debe de tenerse de inmediato
como he dicho varias veces se está
jugando con fuego la central ha sufrido
repetidamente daños por misiles desde
que marzo pasó a estar bajo control ruso
no se han detectado fugas de radiación y
los expertos de loia tienen previsto
inspeccionar la planta en persona el
lunes para hacer un balance de estos
últimos daños